well joining us in the studio to talk
about that and much more as a housing
secretary Robert Jarek thank you very
much for being on the program this
morning good morning I just want to
start with that film and what the bosses
trunkman told me and they're in Dudley
saying that talk of divergence is
unrealistic for his business cuz they
main export partner is the EU and that's
gonna be true for many businesses isn't
it I mean is there a worry that the
government is just talking about
divergence just for the sake of it when
actually the EU is such an important
trading partner well we've left the
European Union now and the question for
this year is going to be whether we
leave the transition period with the
kind of free trade agreement that Canada
has that's our preference that's a
somewhat deeper trading relationship all
the one that we secured last year which
is similar to the relationship that
Australia has and plenty of other
countries you know straight to trade
successfully we already we already have
a deal what we don't want to do a deal
we don't want to align with EU we're not
seeking alignment our standards are
already the same in many cases actually
they're higher including on some of the
things that the public care about very
strongly like the environment like
workers rights and we think committing
to long term alignment is both
unnecessary and is incompatible with the
objective of the government which is to
ensure that we regain in full our
economic and political sovereignty at
the end of the transition period and the
benefits to the UK economy I think will
outweigh any concerns that might come
through a somewhat higher degree of
friction which we're willing to accept
because we don't want alignment and I
think you also heard on that video that
the UK economy has started 2020 in
robust health in my own area in the
housing market that appears to be
picking up you see greater investment
into the UK the certainty that business
and individuals now have as a result of
the election as a result of having a
functioning majority government along
last I think is going to see real
benefits over the course of this year
okay the real test of course is what
happens when that transition comes to an
end we'll have to wait and see and what
the economic situation is there and now
I just want to ask you about a line from
one of my other interviews and I
interviewed Don Butler the contender to
be the deputy leader of the Labour Party
earlier on the show
we were talking about John Bercow and
whether or not he should get a peerage
in the House of Lords she said that if
the concept of party aren't offering the
speaker a peerage because of Brac said
that would be a form of bullying in
itself well well I haven't seen the list
that the prime minister or indeed
anybody else is putting forward for
peerages but personally I wouldn't offer
John Bercow a peerage I think you've
seen some very serious allegations of
bullying and harassment from senior
credible people including a leftenant
general who worked with him these are
important things that need to be
investigated before any decision like
that's taken and in my own experience
Parliament is a better place without
John Bercow and long may that continue
okay a better place without John Burke
Oh important of course to say that John
Barco denies these allegations that the
investigation hasn't of course been
completed and but what do you make of
Dawn but the specific comments saying
that the Conservative Party is
effectively bullying john burke oh by
not offering him a peerage on the
grounds of france said no i don't agree
with that it's that the prime minister
chooses individuals who could sit in the
House of Lords as conservative peers
there's no obligation on the prime
minister to make John Bercow a member of
the House of Lords john burke oh never
believed in convention himself when he
was speaker he explicitly said that he
didn't think that conventions needed to
be abided by he said that if you do that
nothing ever changes so there's no
obligation on the prime minister didn't
every the convention that speakers are
elevated to the House of Lords well john
burke i was the first person you know to
break conventions i think what's
important here is that there should be a
high bar on anybody who ends up in the
house of laws as indeed in the house of
commons and the allegations against john
burke Oh need now to be investigated and
of course a lot of his conduct is there
for all the world to see you because it
was done sitting in the Speaker's chair
in the House of Commons
okay now I'm keen to move on to a couple
of other stories in the news today first
on coronavirus and the news this morning
that more people have now died from
corona virus compared to the SARS
outbreak in 2003 and how worried is the
government well this is a very serious
situation but we have a plan and we're
working very closely with partners all
around the world the NHS is doing a
fantastic job as you know there's a
small number of cases of individuals in
the UK three there are British citizens
overseas who unfortunately have also
contracted the virus nobody we believe
has contracted it in the UK yet the
individuals here contracted it abroad we
have a further flight of British
citizens returning from Wuhan and
landing at Brize Norton later today they
will be looked after by the NHS they're
going to a location in Milton Keynes
where they'll be staying for a period of
time so we're putting in place all of
the plans that we need to to keep the
public safe and of course the Foreign
Commonwealth officers have issued
guidance urging British citizens who are
in China now to make plans to return to
the UK and dissuading British citizens
from going out to China but we will do
everything we can to keep the public
safe and to ensure we work through this
a bit early very difficult situation
okay and another story in the mail on
sunday today confirmed by Sky News and
relates to the case of an cyclists the
woman the driver American driver who
killed Harry Dunne the teenage
motorcyclist fled to the u.s. claiming
diplomatic immunity now there are
reports that she was a former CIA
operative although she wasn't at the
time of the incident do you think that
might explain why the US has been
refusing to extradite her well I don't
know the reasons why the US have have
turned down our request so far to
extradite her she needs to return to the
UK she should face justice and I think
it's a terrible situation I think we all
agree on that for the family that not
only have they lost their child but
they're not seeing somebody brought to
justice for that the government has been
very clear the home secretary patel
requested extradition the Prime Minister
has raised this personally with Donald
Trump and domineer all of the foreign
secretaries a number of occasions with
his opposite numbers and with the US
ambassador here in the UK we hope they
will listen and we hope this lady will
return to the UK and face justice that
is what we owe to the family that's in
this situation that's
most unimaginable to all of us who are
parents it's pretty clear that you hope
the u.s. grants next edition but so far
they've been pretty clear saying that's
not going to happen I mean what does it
say about the influence of the current
government if on this hugely important
issue that there was such agreement here
with that you can't even get Donald
Trump to listen to you
well we're disappointed you know I won't
hide our disappointment that we haven't
reached the resolution we wanted to on
this issue we have a very good and deep
relationship with United States many
issues have a good on this relationship
we're frustrated that we haven't reached
a result that we want yet but I can
assure you they will continue pressing
the case and I want to see I know that
the Prime Minister does as well I want
to see this lady in the UK facing
justice so that of course that doesn't
bring back a child who's been killed but
it does at least go for the family some
of the answers and the justice that they
deserve Jeremy Hunt said the US isn't
behaving like an ally over this to agree
well we are disappointed and frustrated
by this situation and we wanted we
brought to a resolution as soon as
possible
okay now the Prime Minister is expected
to be announcing and some infrastructure
projects later this week of course one
of the biggest infrastructure projects
is gonna be HS to we respecting a
decision on that as well do you want it
to go ahead well I'm not going to
speculate on the decision as you say
it's going to be announced very shortly
what I do know and I'm very pleased
about this is that there's going to be a
big investment in infrastructure we'll
have to wait to find out the exact mix
of projects and I think there will be
arranged so there'll be some big
strategic projects we already know some
of those like our commitment to northern
powerhouse rail for example like the new
east-west railway which links Oxford and
Cambridge that we announced the route on
just a few days ago there'll also be
more local investments as well that make
a real impact on people's lives whether
that's local railways reopening some of
those lines the stations that were cut
by the beach involves filling in
potholes building local roads
regenerating town centers to get better
transport in and out of places where
people go to shop and to work we have
committed that this government will
raise levels of infrastructure
investment to the highest sustained
levels that we've seen as a country
since the nineteen
seventies and that's essential if we're
going to meet the central commitment of
the government which is to unite and to
level up all parts of the country
talking about leveling up talking about
this big infrastructure spend you're
going to have to find the money to do
all this there are reports in The Sunday
Telegraph today that some in the
Treasury number 10 are discussing what
people refer to as a mansion tax so some
kind of tax on wealthy homeowners if you
like is that a fair way of leveling up
would you say well I've been a Treasury
Minister so I've seen the speculation
that happens in the weeks leading up to
a budget and I don't think it's helpful
for me to comment on that or for others
where that's conservative colleagues as
I was saying comment or members of the
cabinet to comment on it what I do know
because I'm working very closely with
the Chancellor is that we're going to
have a great package which does what we
said we would do at the election level
up invest far more in infrastructure
invest in housing so that we get good
quality homes built across the country
as quickly as possible with the
infrastructure that they need and we're
also going to ensure that you know we
have a tax system that encourages
entrepreneurship and investment in the
UK at this crucial moment so you can't
rule out a mansion tax though well I'm
not the Chancellor and even if the
Chancellor was that he himself you would
say that you need to wait to the budget
on the 11th of March what I can say to
you is that this is going to be a budget
which tries to level up parts of the
country that feel undervalued have not
been invested in for a long time and the
work that I'm doing with the Chancellor
on that agenda I think he's going to
have some very exciting outcomes we are
going to be building more homes we're
going to be reforming the planning
system and we're going to be ensuring
that those parts of the country that
need investment in critical
infrastructure get it under this curse
so if you're a well-off homeowner in the
southeast who can probably afford to pay
a bit more tax you should be a bit
worried done though I haven't said that
at all we're gonna have to you're gonna
well the point of leveling up is that
it's not pitting one part of the compass
that one have to games or the other one
has to pay for the leveling up what
we're going to be doing with
infrastructure investment is taking
advantage of historically very low
levels of interest rates
and using that to invest in the
long-term future for a country and that
is the mark of a mature country taking
long term decisions investing for the
future okay now the last time you were
on the program I asked you about
inheritance tax and and I just wanna
have a look at what you said at the time
you said it's a tax which is
particularly unpopular because people
can see the fundamental unfairness of
paying tax twice I can see why the
Chancellor is interested in this one the
context was a Sajid Javid interview
where he been talking about inheritance
tax so would you like to see some
reforms over into inheritance tax
well the Chancellor and I are both low
tax conservatives we want to ensure that
people can keep more of the money that
they earn and we're doing that we've
made some commitment to that in our
manifesto what the Chancellor chooses to
do in the budget is for him and I think
we'll both have to wait and see how
about some cheating if you're a low tax
conservative is that one that you that
we've already taken on stamp duty the
most important decision which was to
take all first-time buyers out of paying
stamp duty below 300 thousand pounds a
year and we're already bringing forward
further proposals to help the housing
market last year we built more homes in
this country than any year in the last
30 years 240,000 the chance and I are
working on making the planning system
work better and I'm ensuring that
first-time buyers can actually get on
the ladder for the first time this week
we just announced our new policy first
homes which offers a 30 percent discount
to local first-time buyers to get on the
ladder now the reshuffle is looming and
you've of course been put for by number
10 to be on the show
there's Sunday morning do you take that
as a quiet vote of confidence or you
won't they might be being particularly
cruel I don't know me this is that this
is a decision of the prime minister
he'll decide who he wants in the cabinet
doesn't sound as if we'll have very long
to wait but I'm very pleased to be doing
this job I think it's the best job in
the government and it is about helping
people onto the housing ladder getting
better homes built safe for homes more
environmentally friendly and leveling up
all parts of the country so that
wherever you're born whether it's my
constituency in Newark or here in West
London you can share all the prosperity
and opportunity of the country Ferriero
message number tunnel-like that I'm sure
there's been some discussion as well
about whether cabinet could be scaled
back I mean this is a picture of the
cabinet table I mean I have to say it's
looking pretty cramped around there
isn't it do you think you could do with
a few spare seats no I look I think I
you're getting me onto dangerous
territory we're gonna have to we're
gonna have to wait and see there's a lot
of talented people you know in the
Conservative Party and the Primus has
got a lot to choose from
okay Robert general thank you very much
for going to the program today thank you